Robert has a whole career of great work
behind him and he was at a point in his
life in his career where he was ready to
break out and do something really big
and exciting Shawn was in love with the
idea of Donnie playing the part and we
all felt so sure about him on a creative
level because he wasn't instantly a
slam-dunk approval I suggested we have
screen tests I remember walking in with
Robert Downey jr. the day of the tests
he was laughing and in great spirits and
completely at ease and he got in front
of the camera and started seeing the
lines I assure you the day weapons are
no longer needed to keep the peace so
I'll happily transistor manufacturing
bricks and beams for baby hospitals
making hemp pants and the like but until
that time can I get your drink
I don't call it an out-of-body
experience but it was one of those
rushes that I'm sure like somebody would
feel if they're about to play a big
sporting arena cleaning for the ring or
something like that it's just like am I
gonna pass out or am I gonna nail this
on that day that Roberts screen tested
it was clear that there was no one else
who can play that part it was magic it
was exactly the feeling is a casting
director with Kevin with John with
everyone that we all wanted to have that
feeling like we have it this is it
this is our man how's it going everybody
it's Warren and Marvel has just released
a brand new feature add that shows
Robert Downey junior screen testing to
be Iron Man for the very first time and
as you just heard from the very
beginning from the very first time that
he screen tested for the role of Iron
Man
everybody knew right away during that
screen test that he was the person that
was going to play Iron Man he was the
perfect fit for Iron Man and he really
was from the very first Iron Man film
that we got that kicked off the MCU all
the way down to Avengers end game from
him becoming Iron Man and Iron Man want
to hem snapping and saving the entire
universe and Avengers end game he was
perfect and what I think is really
awesome and really funny at the same
time is that Robert Downey jr. after all
of this time playing Tony Stark slash
iron man in the MCU sort of became Tony
Stark in real life like when you watch
an Avengers movie or an Iron Man movie
and you see Tony Stark I think that's
exactly
how Robert Downey jr. is in real life
which again is why he was perfect for
the role
sadly Robert Downey jr. 'he's time as
Tony Stark and Iron Man have come to an
end because Tony Stark made the ultimate
sacrifice and saved the entire universe
but of course he will always be
remembered and referenced in the MCU
from here on out and he could even make
some cameos and that could be due to a
flashback a hologram a recorded message
that he did for Morgan Stark another one
that we may not know about but this
probably isn't the last time that you'll
see him in an MCU movie but this is a
really cool feature at that Marvel has
released I want you to let me know what
your favorite Iron Man moment was in the
entirety of the MCU not to be too cliche
but of course my favorite scene in the
MCU for Iron Man was an Avengers end
game where he snapped and said and I am
Iron Man so let me know your favorite
moment for Iron Man in the MCU and don't
forget about my giveaway if you'd like a
chance to win a Iron Man helmet a
Captain America shield and Infinity
Gauntlet or another Marvel Legends item
be sure to subscribe to my channel and
comment down below with your favorite
superhero or villain also please like
the video if you enjoyed it and
subscribe to my channel if you want to
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU including coverage of San
Diego comic-con this weekend as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof